[Musique]
du rock de la folk mais surtout du blues
le festival tracteur blues et de retour
dans la campagne yvelinoise tracteur
blues est né il y a 8 ans avec l'idée
que les petits villages n'avaient pas de
salle de spectacle et l'idée c'était
donc d'amener le spectacle vivant et
pour nous la musique dans les villages
et d'imaginer tout un tout un site en
fait qui pourrait correspondre le temps
d'une soirée à un petit festival en
plein air donc avec une scène qui arrive
avec ce fameux tracteur un village des
artisans un standard restauration des
buvettes et cette année ce sont les
communes de Breuil Bois Robert et
mesdans qui ont vu la scène arriver sur
la place du village grâce à un tracteur
on a la chance de l'avoir cette année ça
fait cinq ans qu'on l'attendait breber
donc c'est un village rural qu'on essaye
de faire vivre au maximum avec ce type
d'animation dans notre commune petite
commune rurale des Yvelines c'est une
chance d'accueillir un festival
d'andergues quand même parmi les
artistes présents à mes dents les élèves
du Conservatoire à rayonnement
départemental hotpoz et le groupe blue
fever bon c'est du blues c'est du roi du
blues c'est du rock blues on va dire
c'est du blues arrangé voilà ouais
on joue rock convivial quoi c'est c'est
venez avec nous c'est venez vous
embarquer venez faire la fête venez
danser venez chanter venez parce que
c'est parce que pour moi c'est la
conception que j'ai du rock c'est la
musique que j'aime et venir faire un
festival tracteur blues ça me paraît
complètement logique avec la musique
qu'on fait parce que c'est effectivement
quelque chose du terroir et pour cette
huitième édition le public est une
nouvelle fois conquis je trouve ça super
c'est vraiment vraiment génial ça anime
c'est génial je trouve que ça permet de
rendre la musique accessible à tout le
monde de plus le fait que ce soit
gratuit c'est enfin c'est super c'est on
n'envoie pas tellement et donc c'est
vraiment génial de pouvoir inciter à ça
au niveau des des groupes qui passent
c'est très très bon je il y a un très
bon niveau sur les deux jours de
festival 6 groupes se sont succédés au
total l'événement a réuni environ 700
personnes